el campo de la economía puede ser
difícil de comprender ya que la economía
está formada por miles de millones de
actores organizados de manera
increíblemente complejas este es el
mundo real y es complejo y cada uno de
estos actores seres humanos u
organizaciones son tremendamente
complejos es muy difícil tratar de
predecir lo que hará una persona durante
el tiempo ni que decir de tratar de
predecir el comportamiento de miles de
millones de personas pero el campo de la
economía ha tomado prestada una idea de
otros campos
por ejemplo en química los científicos
han tratado de comprender el
comportamiento de las moléculas en un
contenedor digamos que son moléculas de
un gas podemos imaginar que dentro de
este contenedor tenemos billones de
moléculas esto va a ser tremendamente
complejo de comprender pero al hacer
algunas suposiciones simplificadas
acerca del tipo de interacciones que
ocurren o no ocurren entre las moléculas
pueden encontrar modelos como la ley del
gas ideal con la que quizá estén o no
familiarizados
clase de química esto relaciona la
presión con el volumen con el número de
partículas que tenemos y con la
temperatura que tiene cuando tenemos
algo que es muy complicado y difícil de
comprender y hacemos suposiciones
simplificadas para ayudarnos a
comprenderlo llegaremos a un modelo esto
también ocurre en otros campos del
conocimiento a veces no es una ecuación
a veces puede ser un organismo simple
por ejemplo en biología el ser humano es
un organismo vivo muy complejo y no sólo
eso también ciertas formas de
experimentación serían poco éticas para
ser realizadas en seres humanos que
hacen los biólogos pues hacen
suposiciones simplificadas o buscan
simplificar el problema al observar
organismos más sencillos quizá podríamos
observar una sola célula o quizá a las
mosquitas de la fruta que son famosas en
el estudio de la genética también
podríamos observar organismos más
complejos como los ratones que son
organismos bastante complejos pero son
más sencillos que un ser humano y de
acuerdo a nuestra ética actual estamos
dispuestos a hacerlo
a un ratón cosas que no le haríamos a un
ser humano es por eso que en la biología
escucharemos términos como modelo ratón
en donde se prueban medicinas en ratones
para tratar de comprender los efectos en
los ratones ya que es un buen indicador
de lo que podría ocurrir en los humanos
de hecho cuando desarrollan un nuevo
medicamento primero lo prueban en
ratones y cuando piensan que funciona en
ellos y es seguro entonces comienzan a
hacer pruebas en seres humanos
los economistas hacen lo mismo aún antes
de la llegada de las computadoras y
modelos computacionales los economistas
hacían suposiciones simplificadas
suposiciones como el que todos los
actores en una economía son racionales
que ya sabemos no es del todo cierto yo
no soy racional todo el tiempo y
definitivamente conozco personas que no
siempre son racionales otra suposición
simplificada es que todas las personas
en una economía tienen el mismo acceso a
la información o que tienen información
perfecta cosas que sabemos no son
necesariamente ciertas en una economía
dependiendo del modelo tendremos ciertas
suposiciones simplificadas que toman
esta cosa enorme y compleja del mundo
real y tratan de descomponer la en
ecuaciones más sencillas o líneas o
gráficas al principio del estudio de la
economía veremos cosas como la frontera
de posibilidades de producción la que
supone que sólo se comercia con dos
cosas y todo lo demás permanece igual o
la noción de st.louis paribus un término
en latín que quiere decir algo así como
mantener constantes todas las demás
variables en el mundo real no podemos
elegir solamente dos cosas y hacer que
todo lo demás se mantenga constante pues
se encuentran operando cientos y miles o
millones de variables si queremos hacer
un modelo entonces si podemos hacer
estas suposiciones lo mismo ocurre con
el famoso precio de equilibrio que
estudiaremos más adelante donde tenemos
la oferta y la demanda y la noción de
equilibrio precios y cantidades aquí
también se tiene este tipo de
suposiciones simplificadas acerca de
actores racionales
perfecta estos modelos económicos son
muy útiles y es por eso que la mayor
parte de las cosas que se estudian en el
primer año del curso de economía son
estos modelos dicho esto siempre debemos
ver estos modelos con cierto
escepticismo y no aceptarlos como una
descripción veraz y absoluta de la
realidad de hecho es aquí cuando los
modelos económicos pueden volverse
peligrosos siempre debemos estar
conscientes de cuáles son las
suposiciones que hacemos de hecho muchos
premios nobel de economía se han
otorgado a personas que revisaron
algunas suposiciones simplificadas y
desarrollaron nuevos modelos otra
dificultad relacionada con la economía
es que es muy difícil comprobar la
aprobarla de forma absoluta en campos
como la química la física o incluso la
biología en donde tenemos sistemas igual
de complejos la economía y el cuerpo
humano son sistemas extremadamente
complejos si yo quiero ver en medicina
cómo funciona cierto medicamento puedo
realizar pruebas clínicas en cientos o
miles
personas administrar el medicamento a la
mitad de ellos y controlar varias
variables pero en la economía no podemos
tomar algunas miles de economías que
luzcan similares y administrar algún
tipo de receta de economía a la mitad de
ellas para ver si nuestro modelo
funciona como pensamos lo importante
aquí es darnos cuenta de que los modelos
son valiosos para diferentes campos
incluyendo la economía pero la economía
se encuentra entre las ciencias sociales
y las ciencias como física y química
porque no podemos realizar experimentos
de la misma forma y porque hacemos
suposiciones simplificadas aunque
sabemos que no son siempre ciertas pero
es la única forma de poder comprender
algo tan complejo del mundo real y con
esto terminamos